the last thing that I want to cover is
that you make sure that you get feedback
from users every step of the way
feedback takes a lot of different forms
and you've already seen how you can
conduct user research to inform your
business idea
you might try incorporating the survey
into your product you could send these
out each week or month to collect
feedback or you might even try and embed
them in some way into your product
social media is another great way to
monitor early usage of your product and
have customers connect to your brand app
ratings user ratings or website ratings
are another way to understand
qualitatively and qualitatively what
users think of your product one app
which is called circa News provides the
following guidance on ratings first they
recommend that you just build a great
product if you don't build a great
product users aren't gonna give you good
ratings in the first place secondly
don't annoy the users you should really
only ask them to rate your product if
they've had a good experience and
they've used the product for a little
bit and finally circa news recommends
that you asked nicely and maybe even
reward your users for rate in the app
for more details about their advice
check out the article which is linked in
the instructor notes finally you should
make customer support everyone's job you
might have a dedicated email or chat
service that lets users talk directly to
employees former CTO and co-founder of
kayak Paul English went so far as
putting a very loud phone in the middle
of the engineers he reasoned that if the
same cost kept coming in then the team
would work quickly to resolve the
problems this would likely resolve the
same problems that other users were
facing no matter which strategy you use
you should think about when you will
intercept users and how you will respond
to them your actions and improvements to
your product can speak just as loudly as
individual follow-ups but do you
remember that these experiences also
contribute to the users experience and
their perception of the product